This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of 2021, if you can believe it. And that means it's time for our annual mini-stories episodes. Mini-stories are joyful little stories that come up in our research for another episode, or maybe there are just some fun things someone told us about that we found really interesting, but they didn't quite warrant a full episode in many months of hard reporting. They're great 99pi stories nonetheless. I love them because I get to interview my colleagues and get told great stories all day. Sometimes I know a little bit about what each producer is going to talk about, but sometimes
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你敢相信的话，2021年已经接近尾声了。这也意味着又到了我们一年一度的迷你故事特辑时间。迷你故事是一些轻松愉快的小故事，它们是在我们为其他单集做研究时偶然发现的，或者可能只是一些别人告诉我们的趣事，我们觉得非常有趣，但在历时多月的艰苦报道中，它们还不足以支撑起完整的一集。尽管如此，它们依然是很棒的99pi故事。我喜欢这些故事，因为我可以整天采访我的同事，听他们讲精彩的故事。有时候我对每个制作人要讲的内容略知一二，但有时
I know nothing, which is very fun. This year, in addition to the staff that you know and love, we have some stories from special guests. Some friends of the show will stop by. This week we have stories of controversial sports logos, copious amounts of geese poop, odd Olympic events, and modernist penguins. I mean, come on, that's a list of stories right there. Stay with us. So I'm here with producer Chris Brube, hey Chris.
我一无所知，这非常有趣。今年，除了大家熟悉和喜爱的员工之外，我们还有一些来自特邀嘉宾的故事。节目的一些老朋友将会做客。本周，我们有关于有争议的体育标志、大量的鹅粪、奇怪的奥运会项目以及现代主义企鹅的故事。我是说，拜托，这可是一大堆精彩的故事。请继续收听。所以我和制作人克里斯·布鲁布在一起，嘿，克里斯。
Hey Roman. So what do you have for us? So Roman, it is the Chris Brube, Hey Chris. Hey, Roman. So what do you have for us? So Roman, it is the most wonderful time of the year. It is NBA basketball season. Isn't that like eight months out of the year? It is, but that doesn't mean it's the majority of the year and also the most wonderful time of the year in my opinion. Roman, we've talked about branding and logos on the show before.
嘿，罗曼。那么你给我们带来了什么？所以罗曼，这是克里斯·布鲁布，嘿克里斯。嘿，罗曼。那么你给我们带来了什么？所以罗曼，这是一年中最好的时光。这就是NBA篮球赛季。那不是一年里有八个月左右吗？确实是，但这并不意味着它占据了一年中的大部分时间，而且在我看来，这也是一年中最好的时光。罗曼，我们以前在节目中讨论过品牌和标志。
And today, I want to talk to you about a logo that is overlooked. Sometimes it is the NBA logo. So it's the logo for the entire league. Take a look. I've sent it over. Tell me what you see. OK, so it is the NBA logo. I have seen it.
今天，我想跟你聊一个被忽视的标志。有时候它就是NBA的标志。所以它是整个联盟的标志。看一看。我发过去了。告诉我你看到了什么。好吧，这就是NBA标志。我见过了。
I think many other people have seen. It is blue and red. And it has the sort of silhouette of a basketball player. He's kind of like in action, has a ball in his hand, it says NBA below it. If you have ever seen an NBA logo, this is the one you've probably seen. So, Roman, the NBA logo, it's elegant, it's also pretty simple, right? It's kind of generic. It's just a person playing basketball. Like nobody's going to want to wear that on a t-shirt or a hat, right? Okay. Okay.
我想很多人都见过。它是蓝红相间的。它有一个类似篮球运动员剪影的图案。他有点像在做动作，手里拿着一个球，下面写着“NBA”。如果你见过NBA标志，这很可能就是你见过的那个。所以，罗曼，NBA标志，它很优雅，也很简单，对吧？它有点普通。它只是一个人在打篮球。好像没人会想把这个穿在T恤上或者戴在帽子上，对吧？好吧。好吧。
Would you be surprised to know this logo is the topic of hot debate among basketball fans? Well, I would be surprised. Yeah, it seems very anodine, very basic. Buckle up, Roman. I have a story for you. So, I called up the sports journalist in Morgan Campbell. We started talking about League Logos and he told me they fall under two categories. You either have a shield.
如果你知道这个标志是篮球迷热议的话题，你会感到惊讶吗？嗯，我会感到惊讶的。是的，它看起来非常平淡无奇，非常基础。系好安全带，罗曼。我有一个故事要讲给你听。所以，我给体育记者摩根·坎贝尔打了电话。我们开始谈论联盟标志，他告诉我它们可以分为两类。要么你有一个盾形徽章。
When you look at Major League Soccer, the NFL, the NHL, they all have different versions of the shield. The shield, it's just like a shield with some letters on it, it's pretty not offensive. The second category of League Logo is the silhouette of a player. So the first league to go with the silhouette was Major League Baseball. They hired a design firm named Sangren and Murtha, and a man named Jerry Dior, made the logo. And Morgan pointed this out to me, there's actually a really serious problem with this
当你看看美国职业足球大联盟、NFL、NHL时，它们都有不同版本的盾形徽章。盾形徽章，就像一个带有几个字母的盾牌，相当无害。第二类联盟标志是球员的剪影。所以第一个采用剪影的联盟是美国职棒大联盟。他们雇佣了一家名为桑格伦和默瑟的设计公司，一个名叫杰瑞·迪尔的人制作了这个标志。摩根向我指出了这一点，这个标志其实有一个非常严重的问题。
logo. Major League Baseball has a you know, a silhouette and red white and blue, of course, of a guy who is either about to hit a baseball that's out of the strike zone, high, because it's headed for his shoulder, or it's about to get hit by a pitch and go take first base. Once he pointed that out, I was like, oh yeah, there's no way he's hitting that ball. That's way too high. That's way high. Yeah. So despite the ball being a little too high, this was a very popular logo when it launched in 1968. And around the same time, the NBA was looking to get its own logo. So a designer named Alan Siegel makes up this silhouette of a man dribbling a basketball. But there's
美国职棒大联盟有一个剪影，当然是红、白、蓝色，里面的人要么正要击打一个飞出好球带的高飞球，因为球正朝他的肩膀飞去，要么他就要被投球击中然后走向一等球垒。一旦他指出这一点，我就想，哦，对啊，他绝对打不到那个球。那太高了。太高了。是的。所以尽管球稍微高了一点，但这个标志在1968年推出时非常受欢迎。大约在同一时间，NBA正在寻找自己的标志。因此，一个名叫阿兰·西格尔的设计师创作了这个正在运球的人的剪影。但有一个
one big difference with this logo. This is not a generic silhouette. It's a real guy. The NBA logo, it's understood that this silhouette is from a still picture of Jerry West. Like all of these leagues, their logo is not connected to a specific player. Whereas the NBA people know, especially older people and people with long memories know that that's Jerry West. So, but how can you really tell? Like the baseball one is just like, there's like a kind of a triangle for a nose, and there's
这个标志有一个重大区别。这不是一个通用的剪影。这是一个真人。NBA标志，大家公认这个剪影源自杰瑞·韦斯特的一张静态照片。就像所有这些联盟一样，他们的标志与特定球员无关。然而NBA的标志，人们知道，特别是年长的人和记忆力好的人知道那是杰瑞·韦斯特。所以，但是你究竟怎么能看出来呢？就像棒球那个标志，就是三角形的鼻子，然后
some more distinct features to the NBA logo, but how can you really tell that's an individual person in that picture? So I had the same question. I mean, it's just a silhouette, like how can you tell it's a specific person? And then I saw the reference photo. So I had the same question. I mean, it's just a silhouette. Like, how can you tell it's a specific person? And then I saw the reference photo. So Roman, here you go. I've sent you the NBA logo and a reference photo of Jerry West. Take a look.
NBA标志有更多明显的特征，但你究竟怎么能看出那张图片里是一个具体的人呢？所以我也有同样的问题。我是说，这只是一个剪影，你怎么能看出它是特定的人呢？然后我看到了参考照片。所以我也有同样的问题。我是说，这只是一个剪影。你怎么能看出它是特定的人呢？然后我看到了参考照片。所以罗曼，给你。我把NBA标志和杰瑞·韦斯特的参考照片发给你了。看一看。
Oh, yeah. That's him, right? That's it. That's the picture. It's pretty undeniably him. It's like the ears are his. It's his haircut in silhouettes. Yeah.
哦，是的。就是他，对吧？就是这样。这就是那张照片。毫无疑问就是他。比如耳朵是他的。剪影里的发型是他的。是的。
Even how his foot is positioned is exactly the reference photo. Like, there's no denying this is Jerry West in the Silhouette. I ease. So unlike you, I am not a big basketball fan. So can you tell me about Jerry West? So Jerry West was one of the greatest basketball players
甚至连他的脚部姿态也和参考照片完全一样。就像，无可否认这就是剪影中的杰瑞·韦斯特。我的天。所以和你不同，我不是一个超级篮球迷。那么你能给我讲讲杰瑞·韦斯特吗？所以杰瑞·韦斯特是60年代最伟大的篮球运动员之一
of the 60s. He's this legend from the LA Lakers. At the time, it makes a lot of sense that they chose him as the logo. But here's the thing, the NBA has never acknowledged that it's him. I mean, probably for good reason, like for legal reasons, yeah.
他是洛杉矶湖人队的传奇人物。在当时，他们选择他作为标志是非常合乎情理的。但问题是，NBA从未承认过那是他。我是说，可能是有充分理由的，比如出于法律原因，是的。
Yeah, I assume they don't want to pay Jerry West Royaltees or admit that they based it on a real guy, so they've actually never admitted that it's him, but every basketball fan knows that it's him. Like Jerry West gets approached on the street by children who are like, you're the NBA logo. His nickname is the logo now.
是的，我猜他们不想付给杰瑞·韦斯特版税，也不想承认它是以真人为基础设计的，所以他们其实从未承认过那是他，但每个篮球迷都知道那是他。就像杰瑞·韦斯特在街上会被小孩子们拦住，他们会说，你就是NBA标志。他现在的绰号就叫“标志”。
Even though he's not officially the logo, no one claims him officially has the logo, but he's called the logo. Exactly. And there's some things about this that are a little bit complicated about Jerry West being the logo, but he's called the logo. Exactly. And there's some things about this that are a little bit complicated about Jerry West being the logo. So the first issue is that Jerry West played in the 1960s,
尽管他不是官方的标志，没有人正式宣称他是标志，但他被称为“标志”。没错。关于杰瑞·韦斯特作为标志，有一些事情有点复杂，但他被称为“标志”。没错。关于杰瑞·韦斯特作为标志，有一些事情有点复杂。所以第一个问题是杰瑞·韦斯特是在20世纪60年代打球的，
that is a very, very different era of basketball. Yeah, well, what it looks like is like a snapshot of freeze frame of the game, the way people use to play it for athletes who are as big and as fast as they are now. So Morgan's point is this is not the silhouette of a modern NBA player. Like, even the posture of the silhouette looks kind of wrong for a modern NBA player. Like, in the 60s, there was no three-point line. Like, it was just a totally different game. So, in that way, it's not very modern.
那是篮球运动一个非常非常不同的时代。是的，嗯，它看起来就像是比赛的一个定格快照，是过去人们打球的方式，而不是像现在的运动员那样高大和迅猛。所以摩根的观点是，这不是现代NBA球员的剪影。甚至剪影的姿势对于现代NBA球员来说看起来都有点不对劲。比如在60年代，还没有三分线。比赛完全是另一回事。所以从这个意义上说，它不是很现代。
I mean, I just could argue that, you know, it's really hard to come up with a generic logo that's modern, so, you know, maybe having an old picture and preserving basketball history in some way, you know, there's something logical about it, you know? Yeah, it's like, maybe you could argue it's a way to preserve the history of the sports to acknowledge a different era.
我的意思是，我可以说，你知道，设计一个现代的通用标志真的很难，所以，你知道，有一张老照片并以某种方式保存篮球历史，你知道，这其中有一定逻辑性，你知道吗？是的，就像，你可能会说这是保存体育历史、承认一个不同时代的一种方式。
This brings us to the second problem, which is a little bit awkward. It's that Jerry West is white. And at the time, most of the NBA players were white. And today, about three quarters of the players in the NBA are black. So a few NBA players have actually brought this up as an issue. They're saying, well, most of the NBA players stay are black. We're being represented by a logo of a white person. Like, what kind of a message does this sound, right? Yeah, that's fair.
这就把我们带到了第二个问题，这有点尴尬。那就是杰瑞·韦斯特是白人。当时，大多数NBA球员都是白人。而今天，NBA中大约四分之三的球员是黑人。所以一些NBA球员实际上把这作为一个问题提了出来。他们说，嗯，现在大多数NBA球员都是黑人。我们却被一个白人的标志所代表。这传递的是什么样的信息呢？是的，这很公平。
Yeah. Then there's the third problem, which is that Jerry West really hates this. He hates that he is the logo. What? Why? So I tried reaching out to Jerry West for this story. He didn't want to talk to me.
是的。然后是第三个问题，那就是杰瑞·韦斯特非常讨厌这个。他讨厌自己成为这个标志。什么？为什么？所以我为了这个故事试着联系杰瑞·韦斯特。他不想跟我谈。
Like, he clearly doesn't like talking about this thing anymore That has dominated the last 50 years of his life But he did talk about it on ESPN a couple of years ago. I wish that Had never gotten out that logo And I've said it more than once and you know, it's flattering if that's me and I know it is me But it is flattering and but if I were the NBA I would be embarrassed about I really would because I don't know I just as a I don't like to do anything to call attention myself and when people say that that's just not who I am Period and if they would want to change it I wish they would
就像，他显然不想再谈论这件事了，这件事主导了他过去的50年人生。但他在几年前的ESPN上谈过这件事。我希望那个标志从来没有流传出去。我止一次说过，你知道，如果那是我的话，这很荣幸，我知道那就是我。但这很荣幸，但如果我是NBA，我会为此感到尴尬，真的会，因为我不知道，作为一个...我不喜欢做任何引起别人注意的事情，当人们说那就是我时，根本就不是我，句号。如果他们想改变它，我希望他们能改变。
In many ways I wish they would want to change it, I wish they would. In many ways, I wish they would. Oh, wow. So he wants them to change it. I mean, you really hear some pathos in his voice there. That's really interesting. So is his wish ever going to come true? Are they going to make that happen? So probably not.
在许多方面，我希望他们想要改变它，我希望他们能改变。在许多方面，我希望他们能改变。哦，哇。所以他希望他们改变。我是说，你真的能从他的声音中听到一种悲怆感。这真的很有趣。那么他的愿望会实现吗？他们会把这变成现实吗？所以可能不会。
And here's a big part of the reason. Nobody can agree what players should replace Jerry West on the logo. If you're going to stick with the silhouette type logo, there is no consensus choice. The one thing basketball fans do better than anyone on this planet is just argue over stuff. Just argue over stuff is LeBron better than Jordan. The Steph Curry deserve to be considered alongside LeBron and Jordan in magic. So imagine the moment you say we're taking Jerry West off of the logo
这就是很大一部分原因。没有人能就哪个球员应该取代杰瑞·韦斯特成为标志达成一致。如果你要坚持使用剪影类型的标志，就没有共识的选择。篮球迷在这个星球上比任何人都擅长的一件事就是争论各种事情。只是争论各种事情，勒布朗是不是比乔丹好？斯蒂芬·库里配不配和勒布朗、乔丹以及魔术师相提并论。所以想象一下，当你宣布我们要把杰瑞·韦斯特从标志上去掉
and looking for a new player to put on the logo. Like NBA, fandom, NBA, Twitter, all of them would implode within 10 minutes. I mean, I guess you could do Michael Jordan because that's the closest you have to a consensus choice. But he already has this iconic silhouette that is used to sell sneakers. So that feels like it's a nonstarter.
并寻找一个新球员放到标志上时。就像NBA球迷群体、NBA推特，所有这些都会在10分钟内崩溃。我的意思是，我想你可以选迈克尔·乔丹，因为那是你拥有的最接近共识的选择。但他已经有了这个用来卖运动鞋的标志性剪影。所以这感觉像是一个无法开始的想法。
I mean, you could do a generic silhouette, but the problem with that is it kind of feels like the horse is out of the barn, like that would make people really upset. Like, basically any choice would make a lot of people really angry. That makes sense to me that that's just the way people argue these days. I mean, did Jerry West have some kind of suggestion? So he's joked about it. He suggested it should be the commissioner of basketball, Adam Silver, which means it would
我是说，你可以用一个通用的剪影，但问题是这感觉有点像木已成舟，覆水难收，那会让人们非常生气的。基本上任何选择都会让很多人非常愤怒。这对我来说很合理，因为现在人们就是这样争论的。我是说，杰瑞·韦斯特有什么建议吗？所以他开过玩笑。他建议应该由篮球事务运营总监亚当·萧华来担任，这意味着它将
be a person in a suit. And that's, I mean, like, that's a terrible choice. I don't want to suggest that Jerry West is wrong here, but Jerry West is wrong here. It should not be Adam Silver, the commissioner of basketball. I agree with you. But recently, one player has kind of emerged as a fan favorite to become the new logo,
是一个穿着西装的人。我的意思是，那是一个糟糕的选择。我不是暗示杰瑞·韦斯特这里错了，但杰瑞·韦斯特这里确实错了。不应该是篮球事务运营总监亚当·萧华。我同意你的看法。但最近，有一个球员作为粉丝的最爱脱颖而出，成为了新的标志，
it's Kobe Bryant. So Bryant died in a helicopter crash last year at the age of 41, and soon after he died, this petition appeared online to make him the logo about three million people have signed it at this point. Bryant's widow is on board, lots of NBA players support the idea. However, yeah, no, I think I know what this however is about. Yeah, his however is about.
那就是科比·布莱恩特。因此，布莱恩特去年在一次直升机坠毁事故中不幸去世，享年41岁，在他去世后不久，网上出现了一份请愿书，要求将他作为标志，目前大约有三百万人签署了这份请愿书。布莱恩特的遗孀表示赞同，很多NBA球员也支持这个想法。然而，是的，不，我想我知道这个“然而”是关于什么的。是的，他的“然而”是关于什么的。
Yeah, his legacy is complicated. You might remember Kobe Bryant was accused of sexual assault in 2003 and the charges were dropped, but he was sued in civil court and he settled out of court and issued a public apology. So, I mean, there's certainly no perfect candidate, but Kobe Bryant would make a lot of people mad if he was the choice for the NBA logo. For sure. So, I guess the other option is they could, you know, just have the shield style one like the
是的，他的传奇人生很复杂。你可能还记得，科比·布莱恩特在2003年被指控性侵，虽然指控被撤销了，但他被民事法庭起诉，并在庭外和解，发表了公开道歉。所以，我是说，当然没有完美的候选人，但如果科比·布莱恩特成为NBA标志的选择，会让很多人感到生气的。肯定的。所以，我猜另一个选择是他们可以，你知道，就像
NFL over the NHL. I mean, other leagues do that. Why not do that? Yeah, I actually mentioned this idea to Morgan and he was like, no way. Let's not do that. And his reason is something that's cool about the NBA is that you do get to see players' personalities. And so, I mean, the difference between the NBA and the NFL is that the NBA, like you can see
NFL或NHL那样采用盾形标志。我的意思是，其他联盟都这样做。为什么不这样做呢？是的，我实际上向摩根提到了这个想法，他的反应是：没门。我们别这么做。他的理由是，NBA酷炫的地方在于你确实能看到球员的个性。所以，我是说，NBA和NFL的区别在于，在NBA，你可以看到
the players' bodies, you can see their faces, you can see their facial expressions, and the sport itself allows for a lot of individual expression, whereas that, all that stuff is one impossible to see in the NFL, because players helmets and two because of the rules like any type of individual expression in spontaneity is frowned upon. That's taunting. How dare you feel good about having made a plate? Roman, do you know what some people call the NFL? No.
球员的身体，你可以看到他们的面部，你可以看到他们的面部表情，这项运动本身允许大量的个性表达，而在NFL中，所有这些东西，一方面因为球员戴着头盔而根本无法看到，另一方面因为规则的限制，任何形式的个性表达和即兴发挥都是不被鼓励的。那是挑衅。你怎么敢因为完成一次精彩表现而自我感觉良好呢？罗曼，你知道有些人怎么称呼NFL吗？不知道。
The no fun league because players are not allowed to really show their personality. But the NBA, it's like they wear outfits before the games. They are allowed to taunt each other. They're like, it's just really fun. That's a big draw of the sport for me. But I think I could make the opposite case that if it is a league full of personalities, that you don't want another personality on the logo
叫“没乐趣联盟”（No Fun League），因为球员不允许真正展现他们的个性。但NBA呢，他们就像是在比赛前穿着各种服装。他们被允许互相挑衅。他们会觉得，这真的很有趣。对我来说，这是这项运动的一大吸引力。但我认为我可以提出相反的观点，如果这是一个充满个性的联盟，你就不希望标志上有另一个个性
to mess with the personalities that are on the court, you know? Baro Man, the shield is so boring. Have you seen it? Have you seen the NFL logo? You know what I have it, and I think it's probably a testament to the fact that it, you know, isn't quite as salient as this one. Totally, and it's something that comes up on our show a lot is the idea that there's kind of no such thing as a generic design, right? Because when you're trying to make something very unspecific and uncontroversial, you're still making choices, right? Like you're still communicating something.
来干扰球场上的那些个性，你知道吗？拜托，罗曼，那个盾形标志太无聊了。你见过吗？你见过NFL的标志吗？你知道我见过，而且我认为这可能证明了这样一个事实，即它，你知道，不像这个标志那么引人注目。完全正确，这也是我们节目经常讨论的一个观点，即某种程度上不存在所谓的通用设计，对吧？因为当你试图把某样东西做得非常不具体、没有争议时，你其实仍然在做选择，对吧？就像你仍然在传达某种东西。
So yeah, there's even bias in that notion to make something generic and it always comes through and it just is one of the reasons why Design is always so fascinating. Well, I am certainly much more fascinated by the NBA logo than I was before this started. So thank you for giving me a new way to look at it. Thanks again to Morgan Campbell, who spoke to us. You can find his writing at the CBC and in the New York Times. And he has a show on YouTube called Bring It In, which I like a lot. I would strongly recommend checking it out. Cool. All right. Thanks Chris.
所以是的，即使在“把某事做成通用的”这种观念中也存在偏见，而这种偏见总是会显现出来，这也是设计总是如此令人着迷的原因之一。好吧，我对NBA标志的着迷程度确实比开始之前要深得多了。所以谢谢你给我提供了一种看待它的新方式。再次感谢接受我们采访的摩根·坎贝尔。你可以在CBC和《纽约时报》上找到他的文章。他在YouTube上有一个名为《Bring It In》的节目，我很喜欢。我强烈建议大家去看看。酷。好的。谢谢你，克里斯。
Thanks, Robin. I'm talking with popular science writer Mary Roach, author of such books as Stiff, Gulp, and Packing from Mars. Her most recent is the best seller called Fuzz. When nature breaks the law, it's all about the unpredictable and fraught interactions between humans and wildlife. And it's so much fun, it's so engaging. And like all of your other books, it's full of footnotes, which I particularly love.
谢谢你，罗曼。我正在与科普作家玛丽·罗奇对话，她著有《僵尸：人类身体的奇异旅程》、《吞咽：动物与人类进食的奇妙科学》以及《火星行李箱》等书。她最近的一本畅销书叫《毛茸茸的罪犯：当自然打破法律》（Fuzz: When Nature Breaks the Law），这本书完全关于人类与野生动物之间难以预测且充满紧张关系的互动。这本书非常有趣，非常吸引人。而且就像你的其他所有书籍一样，它充满了脚注，我特别喜欢这一点。
Can you tell me how you use footnotes, why you use footnotes, and what do they do for you in the text? Yeah, they're not normal footnotes, Roman. They're not footnotes the way intelligence scholarly people use footnotes. They're just moments where I have this material that I found and I love it very much and it cracks me up. But I can't find a way to shoehorn it in. It's too long to set it off with parentheses or m dashes. It's too much, it just derails the flow,
你能告诉我你是如何使用脚注的吗？你为什么使用脚注？它们在文本中为你起到了什么作用？是的，它们不是普通的脚注，罗曼。它们不是聪明博学的学者们使用的那种脚注。它们只是这样一些时刻：我找到了这些材料，我非常喜欢它们，它们让我大笑。但我找不到把它们硬塞进去的方法。用括号或破折号把它隔开太长了。这太多了，它只会破坏行文的流畅度，
however much flow I ever have. So I insist on keeping it in and I put it in a footnote. And my editor, I think initially she didn't realize what the worse, she was going to put them at the end of the chapter. I'm like, no, no, no, it's not that kind of footnote. I think she she didn't realize what the worst she was going to put them at the end of the chapter I'm like no no no it's not that kind of footnote I think she like most people was just skipping them But anyway, she agreed that we could put them on the page and they're just It's just material that is hilarious or bizarre or just It's just me being self-indulgent and wanting that material in there even though it doesn't really fit.
不管我曾经拥有过多少行文流畅度。所以我坚持把它留下来，我把它放进了脚注里。我的编辑，我想她最初并没有意识到会更糟糕，她打算把它们放在章节末尾。我说，不，不，不，不是那种脚注。我想她...她没有意识到会更糟糕，她打算把它们放在章节末尾。我说，不，不，不，不是那种脚注。我想她像大多数人一样只是跳过了它们。不过不管怎样，她同意我们可以把它们放在页面上，它们只是...它们只是一些极其搞笑、光怪陆离的材料，或者只是...只是我有些自我纵容，即使这些材料并不太合适，我也想把它们放进去。
And I personally love them because they are like a window into your mind, which is a mind I enjoy spending time with. They're definitely that. The footnotes are really like kind of an analog to how we do many stories at the end of the year. They're just joyful little aside that don't constitute a book or a chapter, even a paragraph in the main text, you know? They're just kind of like their own thing. And so I was hoping that in our mini stories episode,
我个人非常喜欢它们，因为它们就像是你心灵的一扇窗户，而我喜欢花时间去了解这样的一心灵。它们绝对是这样的。这些脚注确实有点类似于我们在年底制作迷你故事的方式。它们只是些快乐的小插曲，构不成一本书或一章，甚至构不成正文中的一个段落，你知道吗？它们就像是它们自己的独立存在。所以我希望在我们的迷你故事特辑中，
you could share with me one or two of your favorite footnotes from the book and the context for how they both maybe fit in or didn't fit into the main part of the text of us. I would love to. Okay. This one has to do with Canada Geese and and I was originally going to have a Canada goose chapter.
你能跟我分享书中一两个你最喜欢的脚注，以及它们如何契合或未能契合正文背景的故事。我很乐意。好的。这个跟加拿大雁有关，而且我原本打算写一个关于加拿大雁的章节。
I was going to learn to be an egg addler. We don't need to get into right here, but egg addling, it isn't done very much anymore. I couldn't get trained as an egg addler. I know you said you didn't want to get into it, but could you just quickly tell me what an egg addler is? Yeah, sure. If you take an egg and you a goose egg say and you shake it or you coat it in oil, there's another way to do it. It kills the little embryo inside. So people who want to get rid of Canada geese in a humane way will practice egg addling. They'll shake the egg,
我本来要学习如何成为一个雁蛋摇匀员。我们不需要在这里深入探讨，但摇匀雁蛋这种事现在已经不怎么做了。我没能接受培训成为一名雁蛋摇匀员。我知道你说过你不想深入探讨，但你能简单告诉我什么是雁蛋摇匀员吗？好的，没问题。如果你拿一个蛋，比如说鹅蛋，然后你摇晃它或者在它表面涂上一层油，还有另一种方法。这会杀死里面的小胚胎。所以那些想要以人道方式摆脱加拿大雁的人会练习摇匀雁蛋。他们会摇晃这个蛋，
but you have to be sure that it's not far enough along that the embryo is considered more goose than embryo. So it's kind of goose abortion in a way. And people have done a lot of work looking at, you know, if the egg floats, it means there's more air than goose. So it's okay to add it. So, you know, it's, but it's a lot of work because of the bucket of the water and floating the, all the eggs to make sure it's, it's, but it's a lot of work because of the bucket of the water and floating the, all the eggs to make sure it's, it's a humane killing. And also the geese come at you pretty angrily. You have to carry an umbrella and open up the umbrella at them to scare them away. So you kind of look like, is there a Batman character?
但你必须确保它发育得还不够成熟，以至于胚胎被认为更像一只鹅而不是胚胎。所以从某种意义上说，这有点像针对鹅的堕胎。人们做了很多研究，比如如果蛋能浮起来，就意味着里面空气比鹅多。所以把它摇匀是可以的。所以，你知道，这需要很多工作，因为要准备一桶水，把所有的蛋都放进去漂浮，以确保它...这需要很多工作，因为要准备一桶水，把所有的蛋都放进去漂浮，以确保它...这是一种人道的杀戮方式。而且鹅会非常愤怒地向你冲过来。你必须随身携带一把伞，并向它们撑开雨伞把它们吓跑。所以你看起来有点像，有没有哪个蝙蝠侠角色？
The penguin, yeah, sure. The penguin, yeah. So you, and I, that appealed to me that whole scenario with the umbrella and the bucket in the eggs, but it couldn't find anyone to train me. So the whole chapter is gone, the Canada, but I, you know, I have trouble letting go of the Canada geese. So I have a part of the book where I'm talking to someone at the Vatican about, you know, about, you know, do we have the right to destroy animals? And for what reason? Like, at what, can you call certain animals a pest and then ethically kill them? It's this conversation with this poor guy, the pontifical academy for life, who doesn't really understand why he's having to have this conversation. Anyway, we're talking about Canada geese. And I'm saying,
企鹅人，没错。企鹅人，是的。所以你，而且，整个撑伞、拿水桶和鸡蛋的场景很吸引我，但我找不到任何人来培训我。所以整个章节都没了，关于加拿大的部分，但我，你知道，我很难放下加拿大雁。所以我书里有一部分是在梵蒂冈和某人谈论，你知道，关于，你知道，我们是否有权消灭动物？出于什么原因？比如在什么情况下，你可以把某些动物称为害兽然后合乎道德地消灭它们？这是与这个可怜家伙的对话，他是宗座生命科学院的，他真的不明白自己为什么要进行这场对话。不管怎样，我们在谈论加拿大雁。我说，
you know, what is their crime? They crap. That's it. That's the only thing. They're not, they're not harming anyone. They're not posing a danger. They crap on lawns. So in golf courses. And so, you know, maybe we should get rid of golf courses and not geese. Anyways, this whole conversation with this poor guy. But I want it. Here's the footnote, because I'm saying, what is their crime? They crap a lot, Canada geese crap a lot. And then here's the footnote. Okay.
你知道，它们的罪行是什么？它们拉屎。就是这样。这是唯一的罪行。它们没有，它们没有伤害任何人。它们没有构成危险。它们在草坪上拉屎。在高尔夫球场上也是。所以，你知道，也许我们应该除掉高尔夫球场而不是鹅。总之，这就是与这个可怜家伙的整个对话。但我要讲的是。这个脚注来了，因为我说，它们的罪行是什么？它们拉了很多屎，加拿大雁拉了很多屎。然后这就是脚注。好的。
But not as heavily as the internet would have you believe. Goosebusters has them extruding three to four pounds a day. The geese police superintendent at the National Mall in Washington, D.C. claims 2-3 pounds a day per goose. A Boston City Councilor, quote, as much as 3 pounds per day. The Canada Goose fecal smear campaign appears to have hit its zenith in New Jersey's Montclair local newspaper. Quote, an adult Canada goose can weigh up to 20 pounds and defecates more than twice its weight daily. That would be 40 pounds a day coming out of a single goose.
但没有互联网让你相信的那么夸张。“捉鹅大队”（Goosebusters）称它们每天排泄三到四磅。华盛顿特区国家广场的捕鹅总监声称每只鹅每天排泄两到三磅。波士顿市的一位议员说：“每天多达3磅。”针对加拿大雁的粪便抹黑运动似乎在新泽西州蒙特克莱尔当地报纸达到了顶峰。引述：“一只成年加拿大雁体重可达20磅，每天排泄的粪便超过其自身体重的两倍。”那将是单只鹅每天拉出40磅的粪便。
That is how much a horse makes. The reporter cited the USDA, a contact at their National Wildlife Research Center, Public Affairs Office, steered me to the USDA Geese Ducks and Coots Fact sheet, which gives a daily total of 1.5 pounds. The author of the USDA Fact sheet got his information from a Virginia Tech University Cooperative Extension Goose Fact sheet. That fact sheet says studies have shown, but does not cite any studies. A Google Scholar search brings up just one researcher,
这和一匹马排泄的量一样多。这位记者引用了美国农业部（USDA）的数据，他们国家野生动物研究中心公共事务办公室的一位联系人向我推荐了美国农业部《鹅、鸭和美洲骨顶事实说明书》，该说明书给出的每日总量是1.5磅。美国农业部事实说明书的作者的信息来源于弗吉尼亚理工大学合作推广处的《鹅事实说明书》。该说明书称“研究表明”，但并未引用任何研究。谷歌学术搜索只找到了一位研究人员，
B.A. Mani, who actually went out and weighed some turds. Mani's finding the average total wet weight of a Canada goose's daily droppings is just a third of a pound. So where did Virginia Tech get the 1.5 pound per day figure? The author did not reply to multiple emails and so it remains a mystery. Poundage aside, the Canada Ghost is a frequent crapper, 28 times a day on average, manny found. In related research, a Canadian team reports that, quote, sleeping geese sometimes produce small piles of droppings. You're doing God's work Mary. So do you want to set up the second footnote from Files that you have for us?
B.A.曼尼（B.A. Mani），他实际上出去称过一些粪便。曼尼的发现是，加拿大雁每日粪便的平均总湿重仅为三分之一磅。那么弗吉尼亚理工大学是从哪里得出每天1.5磅这个数字的呢？作者没有回复多封电子邮件，所以这仍然是个谜。抛开重量不谈，加拿大雁是个频繁排泄的动物，曼尼发现它们平均每天排泄28次。在相关的研究中，一个加拿大团队报告说：“引述：正在睡觉的鹅有时会产生一小堆粪便。”你这是在替天行道，玛丽。那么你想介绍一下你为我们准备的《毛茸茸的罪犯》一书中的第二个脚注吗？
So the other footnote I want to share is kind of related in that it's another instance where I'm trying to get to the bottom of something and they won't call me back. They won't write to me. You know, it's dealing with public affairs people and publicity people and that constant struggle to get people who understandably don't want to talk to me. I get a lot. Okay, this has to do with around the time of World War II. There were a number of around the time of World War II. There were a number of poisons that the National Defense Research Committee, they were working with the Wildlife Research Laboratory. They were looking for new rat poisons, and they were trying out some of the poisons that the government had experimented with for human warfare. One of them was ricein. But the code name for ricein was compound w. And so I'm familiar with compound w as a wart remover. And I was curious whether the compound w people knew
我想分享的另一个脚注有点相关，因为这是另一个例子：我试图弄清某件事的真相，但他们不给我回电话。他们不给我写信。你知道，这涉及到公共事务人员和宣传人员，以及为了让那些情有可原、根本不想跟我说话的人开口而进行的持续挣扎。我经常遇到这种情况。好吧，这与二战期间有关。二战期间有许多...二战期间有许多...国家国防研究委员会掌握的毒药，他们正在与野生动物研究实验室合作。他们在寻找新的老鼠毒药，并且在试验政府曾为人类战争做过实验的一些毒药。其中一种是蓖麻毒素。但蓖麻毒素的代号是“化合物W”（Compound W）。所以我对作为去除疣的非处方药的“化合物W”很熟悉。我很好奇“化合物W”的人是否知道
that this was a code name for ricein, whether that mattered to them, whether possibly it was an in joke. Anyway, I had a lot of questions for these folks at CompoundW. And here's the footnote. Did the makers of the Wart Removal Product CompoundW realize this when they named their product? I don't know because prestige brands, which owns CompoundW, doesn't return calls. And their online media query form is a dead end and they are not on Twitter. But while we're on the topic of inappropriate names, let's consider prestige brands.
这是蓖麻毒素的代号，这对他来说是否重要，或者这可能是一个内部玩笑。总之，我对“化合物W”的这些工作人员有很多疑问。这就是脚注。生产去疣产品“化合物W”的制造商在给产品命名时意识到这一点了吗？我不知道，因为拥有“化合物W”的知名品牌（Prestige Brands）不回电话。他们的在线媒体咨询表是个死胡同，而且他们不在推特上。但既然我们谈到了不恰当的名字，让我们来看看知名品牌。
Because here are some more of their prestige brands. Fleet Enemas, Nix for Lice, Bino for Flaxlints, Yuri Stat, Nostrilla, Deacon, Nostrilla decadstant, Nostrilla decadgestant, summer's eve douche, boil ease, effordant denture cleaner, and budros butt paste. Those are all prestige brands.
因为这里还有更多他们的知名品牌。舰队灌肠剂（Fleet Enemas）、用于治疗虱子的尼克斯（Nix）、治疗肠胃胀气的拜诺（Bino）、尿酸清除剂（Yuri Stat）、诺斯特拉（Nostrilla）、迪肯（Deacon）、诺斯特拉减充血剂、萨默斯夏娃洗液（Summer's Eve douche）、博伊利斯（Boil Ease）、保洁洁假牙清洁剂（Efferdent denture cleaner）以及布德罗屁屁膏（Budros butt paste）。这些全都是知名品牌。
That's my favorite footnote. I'll probably find products that do their job well. They probably do their quite procedurally. It's kind of like if Mary Roach owned a product company, a corporate product company, that's what it would sell. I mean, I have a real affinity for these people even though they won't get back to me. Well, maybe next time they will. Yeah. So thank you so much for giving us a guide through your footnotes. And if you want to read, you know, the accompanying text that encircles these footnotes, the book fuzz is so great.
那是我的我最喜欢的脚注。我可能会找到那些工作做得很出色的产品。它们可能相当程序化地完成了工作。这有点像如果玛丽·罗奇拥有一家产品公司，一家企业产品公司，那就会出售这些东西。我的意思是，我对这些人有着真正的亲切感，尽管他们不回我的电话。好吧，也许下次他们会。是的。非常感谢你带我们领略你的脚注。如果你想阅读围绕这些脚注的配套文本，那本《毛茸茸的罪犯》真的很棒。
I enjoyed every minute reading it. So thank you so much for writing it and for coming on the show. Thanks so much, Roman. I always enjoy it. The Olympic games seem almost timeless, going back to ancient Greece. So it can be easy to forget that the modern games as we know them today were only launched just over a century ago. Croakholz did this here with some lesser known modern Olympic history from when the games
我享受阅读它的每一分钟。非常感谢你写了这本书，并来到我们的节目。非常感谢，罗曼。我总是乐在其中。奥运会似乎近乎永恒，可以追溯到古希腊。因此，人们很容易忘记，我们今天所知道的现代奥运会在一个多世纪前才刚刚诞生。克罗克霍尔茨今天在这里为我们讲述一些鲜为人知的现代奥运会历史，当时奥运会
were still being shaped into the international event we know today. That's right. And to get things started, Roman, I'm going to have you read the first stanza of a poem. It's titled ode to sport and it was written in 1912 16 years after the first modern Olympic Games. Okay, here we go. Oh Sport pleasure of the gods essence of life. You appeared suddenly in the midst of the gray clearing Which rives with the drudgery of modern existence, like the radiant messenger of a past age when mankind still smiled, and the glimmer of
还在被塑造为我们今天所熟知的国际赛事。没错。为了拉开序幕，罗曼，我要请你朗读一首诗的第一节。它名为《颂体育》，写于1912年，即第一届现代奥运会举办16年后。好的，我们开始。啊，体育，天神的快乐，生命的精华。你突然出现在灰色空地的中央，这空地被现代生存的苦役所撕裂，就像一个过去时代的灿烂使者，那时人类还在微笑，晨曦的微光
dawn lit up the mountain tops and flux of light dotted the ground in the gloomy forests. Well done, that was excellent. So other than them having a really dim view of the modern condition, what is that poem about? Well, see, it's not just any poem. It's an Olympic poem. And I don't mean that it's a poem about the Olympics. I mean, it literally won an Olympic gold medal for literature. Okay, okay. I mean, I don't know about every sport in the Olympics, but I'm pretty short of literature is not one
照亮了山顶，光束在阴暗森林的地面上洒下点点斑驳。干得好，太棒了。那么，除了他们对现代状况的悲观看法之外，这首诗是关于什么的？你看，这可不是一首普通的诗。这是一首奥运诗。我不是指一首关于奥运会的诗。我是说，它实打实地赢得了奥运会文学金牌。好吧，好吧。我是说，我并不了解奥运会的所有项目，但我非常确信文学绝对不是一个我熟悉的
that I'm familiar with at all. Yeah, you're right. And nobody is today for the most part. But for decades, the Olympic Games actually did include competitions that fell under these five main artistic categories, and one of those was literature. And so because I only think of them as sporting events and the Catalan's and Pentathlon's, how did literature find its way into the Olympics?
项目。是的，你说的对。在今天，大多数人确实都不了解。但在几十年来，奥运会实际上确实包含属于这五个主要艺术类别的比赛，其中之一就是文学。既然我只把它们当作体育赛事以及全能比赛和五项全能，文学是如何进入奥运会的呢？
Well, it started with this person who was broadly credited with watching the modern Olympics, Pierre de Coubertin, and he was this French aristocrat who advocated for and then ultimately organized the International Olympic Committee, which is still around today. So he's at the forefront of Olympics in general, and that committee decided to host the very first modern international Olympics in 1896. And they chose Athens as the host city, which was of course a nod to the ancient Greek Olympics. So the first modern games in Athens, they did both feature like sports and arts like that? Well, not quite yet. The very first set of games was basically what you'd expect.
这要从被广泛认为发起现代奥运会的这个人说起，他就是皮埃尔·德·顾拜旦，他是一位法国贵族，倡导并最终组织了至今仍然存在的国际奥林匹克委员会。所以他是奥运会总体的领军人物，该委员会决定在1896年举办第一届现代国际奥运会。他们选择雅典作为主办城市，这当然是对古希腊奥运会的致敬。所以雅典的第一届现代奥运会，它们既有体育运动，也有这样的艺术活动吗？嗯，还不太算。最初的一届比赛基本上就是你所期望的那样。
It had sports like swimming and weightlifting and fencing. But then after we'd had a couple of good successful games, also dirt around sports, Kubrita sprung this idea on the IOC in 1906. He basically was like, here we go. Why don't we also add these arts categories I've been thinking about? And those were architecture, literature, music, painting, and sculpture. Architecture. Now we're cooking our cats here. Okay, keep going. And so these architects and other artists participating in this new quote, pan-tathlon of the muses, and quote, were supposed to be amateurs, much like their counterparts competing on the sports side. It all seems like a pretty big departure from what I think of as the ancient Olympics were
它有游泳、举重和击剑等运动。但在我们举办了几届相当成功的比赛、一切围绕体育展开之后，顾拜旦在1906年向国际奥委会提出了这个想法。他基本上是说，我们开始吧。为什么我们不把我也一直在考虑的这些艺术类别也加进去呢？这些类别是建筑、文学、音乐、绘画和雕塑。建筑。这下我们可真有得玩了。好吧，继续。所以这些参与这个新的所谓的“缪斯五项全能”（Pan-tathlon of the muses）的建筑师和其他艺术家，应该像在体育赛 spoke 场上竞争的同行一样是业余爱好者。这看起来与我所认为的古希腊奥运会有很大的不同，古希腊奥运会
those always centered around sports too? I mean, they were for the most part, but there were some ancient Olympic competitions for music or singing or even what's called heralding, which I gather just involve announcing things really loudly. I don't know. And so Cooper Ten kind of referred to that in his arguments for including the arts and the modern Olympics. And he wrote quote, in the high times of Olympia, the fine arts were combined harmoniously with the Olympic Games to create their glory. This is to become reality once again." But and I find this part strange for some reason, all of these artistic entries were also supposed to be related to sports.
也总是以体育为中心吗？我的意思是，它们主要是以体育为中心，但也有一些古希腊奥运会比赛是关于音乐、歌唱甚至被称为“宣读员”的比赛，据我了解，这只涉及非常大声地宣布事情。我不知道。所以顾拜旦在为将艺术纳入现代奥运会进行辩护时提到了这一点，他写道：“在奥林匹亚的全盛时期，美术与奥林匹克运动和谐结合，创造了它们的辉煌。这一切将再次成为现实。”但是——出于某种原因我觉得这部分很奇怪——所有这些艺术参赛作品也都必须与体育相关。
I mean, the poem you had me read at the top was like that. It was about sports. I mean, I don't know if like, if you were judging all poems equally, if one about sports would necessarily win the gold medal, but when it comes to poems in the Olympics during this era, they had to be about sports. Correct. Yeah, exactly. So it was kind of limiting.
我的意思是，你刚才让我朗读的开头的诗就是这样的。它是关于体育的。我是说，我不知道，如果你以同等标准评判所有的诗歌，一首关于体育的诗是否一定会赢得金牌，但说到这个时期的奥运会诗歌，它们必须是关于体育的。没错。是的，完全正确。所以这有点局限性。
And so in the realm of architecture, for example, contenders submitted stuff like athletic stadiums and sporting complexes and playing fields and swimming pools and even ski jumps. And some of those pieces were published during the Olympics, like that's where they kind of first appeared, but others were actually built structures like out in the world.
因此，在建筑领域，例如，竞争者提交的作品包括运动场、体育综合体、运动场、游泳池甚至滑雪跳台。其中一些作品在奥运会期间出版——就像那是它们首次亮相的地方——但其他作品实际上是现实世界中建造的结构。
So they were judging actual built structures. It's not just like how did you bring your building to Athens? Like how did you bring your building to Athens? Like, how did that work? Right. So in those cases, whether or not the thing was built, they relied on renderings. But there were exceptions. So in the 1928 games in Amsterdam, there was this Dutch architect who won the gold medal
所以他们是在评判实际建造的结构。这不只是像“你怎么把你的建筑带到雅典”？就像，你怎么把你的建筑带到雅典？这到底是怎么运作的？是的。所以在这些情况下，无论该建筑是否被建造，他们都依赖效果图。但也有例外。因此在1928年阿姆斯特丹奥运会上，有一位荷兰建筑师赢得了金牌，
for the stadium that was being used in those Olympics. Talk about a home field advantage. Right, I mean, it does seem like it being there, maybe could skew the judges a little bit. But the crazy thing is, by this time, there were a lot of submissions. That year, though, and there were over 1,000 works of art submitted in all these different categories.
因为他设计了那届奥运会上使用的体育场。真可谓主场优势。是的，我的意思是，它在那里，可能确实会稍微影响裁判的判断。但疯狂的是，到这个时候，已经有很多参赛作品了。不过那一年，在所有不同的类别中，有1,000多件艺术作品被提交。
Wow. It's kind of amazing to me that there was a period of time where there were that many submissions and it was that big a part of the games, but no one knows about this period of time. I mean, the Olympics history. Right. Like, I didn't either. I mean, you know, I went to architecture school. You'd think that they would teach you about the architectural Olympics.
哇。对我来说有点惊讶的是，曾有一段时间有这么多的参赛作品，它也是奥运会如此重要的一部分，但没有人知道这段历史。我是说，奥运会历史。没错。就像，我也不知道。我是说，你知道，我上过建筑学校。你本以为他们会教你关于建筑奥运会的知识。
But no, they kind of faded from memory. But for a long time, they were really a big deal. And the IOC even got to the point of adding new subcategories within the arts, like orchestra and dramatic works, even town planning. Yeah, all right. And so these creative competitions grew popular. And one side effect was that they started to naturally draw in people who were more like aspiring professionals and even veteran creatives. And some of these participating artists were even selling their artworks during the games.
但并没有，它们渐渐淡出了人们的记忆。但在很长一段时间里，它们确实是一件大事。国际奥委会甚至还在艺术类中增加了新的子类别，比如管弦乐和戏剧作品，甚至城市规划。是的，没错。所以这些创意比赛越来越受欢迎。而一个副作用是，它们开始自然地吸引那些更像是有抱负的专业人士甚至资深创意人士的人。其中一些参与的艺术家甚至在奥运会期间出售他们的艺术品。
Well, that seems to be somewhat in the violation of the spirit of the games, you know, just to use it as a showcase for selling your work, it's like a big gallery show. Right. If the act of being in the games turns you from an amateur to a professional, then that makes things kind of complicated. It does. And really this idea of amateurism was something that the IOC was pushing more and more
嗯，这似乎有点违背运动会的精神，你知道的，只是把它当成推销自己作品的橱窗，就像一个大型画廊展览。没错。如果参加运动会这一行为让你从业余选手变成专业选手，那么事情就会变得有点复杂。确实如此。事实上，这种业余主义的想法正是国际奥委会随着时间推移在20世纪40年代越来越极力推崇的
as time went on and we were getting into the 1940s. So the arts became this natural target, right? Like it was the obvious thing that was like not being quite as amateur as everybody thought it would be. And frankly, you know, this amateur focus to begin with was a bit of a stretch for the arts. And that architect who won the award for building that Olympic stadium, like obviously he wasn't an amateur.
随着时间的推移，我们进入了20世纪40年代。所以艺术就成了这样一个自然的靶子，对吧？就像这是一件很明显的事情，它没有大家想象的那么业余。坦白说，你知道的，这种业余的定位一开始对艺术来说就有点勉强。而那个因建造奥运体育场而获奖的建筑师，显然他不是一个业余选手。
Right. Yeah. You couldn't oppose the Olympic Games in the amateur stadium, you know, like with amateur adherence to building guidelines for it. Right, right. Just like a rough sketch of an idea, you know, it's still fine. And there were other problems too. Like some artists didn't want to participate because they might lose and that could damage
对啊。是的。你不能在业余体育场里举办奥运会，你知道的，比如用对建筑准则的业余遵循来建造它。对的，对的。就像一个想法的粗略草图，你知道的，这其实也挺好。而且还有其他问题。比如有些艺术家不想参加，因为他们可能会输，这会损害
their reputation. And then, you know, as you mentioned before, it's like this sports focus was pretty limiting. And so eventually, after the London Games in 48, the IOC just discontinued the arts competitions all together. And now there's this thing called the Cultural Olympiad, which is separate, but really like the main events and the medals are four sports. I mean, that is stunning to me that it lasted until 1948. So that means that there's like a stretch of like 30 years or more where there were these artistic metal winners, like,
他们的声誉。然后，你知道的，正如你之前提到的，这种对体育的专注是相当局限的。所以最终，在48年伦敦奥运会之后，国际奥委会干脆彻底取消了艺术比赛。现在有一个叫文化奥林匹亚的东西，它是独立的，但实际上主要活动和奖牌还是为了体育。我的意思是，这让我觉得很震惊，它居然一直持续到了1948年。也就是说，有大概30年或更长的时间里，存在着这些艺术奖牌得主，比如，
are there anybody that I would know of in that cohort? You know, most of them aren't famous people for better or for worse. Like, the ones I actually find most interesting are these like, like, ways in which they kind of like pushed the idea of the Olympics or like, things that like set unusual records. So, for example, there was this Olympian in 1912 who won a medal for swimming while he also won a medal for sculpture. Like, to me, that's really cool. Like that's like, wow, that's really the liberal arts of competition, right? You can like win an art in sports.
在那个群体里有我认识的人吗？你知道的，他们大多数都不是什么名人，无论好坏。比如，我实际上觉得最有趣的是，它们以某种方式推动了奥运会的理念，或者创造了不寻常的纪录。例如，1912年有一位奥运选手，他在赢得游泳奖牌的同时，还赢得了一枚雕塑奖牌。对，我觉得这真的很酷。就像，哇，这真的是竞技中的文科教育，对吧？你既可以在艺术上获奖，也可以在体育上获奖。
And then there was this winner in the arts who was 73 years old when he won. You know, we think of Olympic contenders being pretty young, but it's like in the arts, really any age can apply. And then there's Kubran himself who won a gold medal in an arts category in the 1912 Paris Olympics. Wait a second I mean he helped jumpstart the Olympics like sort of the founder of the modern Olympics and then he competed in the Olympics. Yes, yes he did. And he won his award for literature or more specifically poetry.
然后艺术组还有一个得奖者，他获奖时已经73岁了。你知道的，我们认为奥运选手都很年轻，但在艺术界，真的任何年龄的人都可以报名。然后库柏坦本人在1912年巴黎奥运会上获得了一个艺术类别的金牌。等一下，我的意思是，他帮助启动了奥运会，可以说是现代奥运会的创始人，然后他参加了奥运会？是的，是的，他参加了。他因为文学奖项而获奖，或者更准确地说是诗歌。
Did he write that poem at the top that you made me read? That's the one Cooper-Tan submitted it under a pseudonym and he won the gold. Well, I'm sure there's nothing fishy going on there. No, not at all, not at all. And you know, I mean, there is this possibility that he submitted it because he wanted to make sure all the art categories were represented,
他写了你刚才让我读的那首诗吗？就是库柏坦用化名提交的那首，然后他赢得了金牌。嗯，我确信这其中没有什么猫腻。不，一点也没有，完全没有。你知道的，我的意思是，有一种可能是他提交这篇作品是因为他想确保所有的艺术类别都有代表，
you know, the first year that the arts were included. But obviously, I can't help but wonder if he was secretly harboring a second motive. I mean, he put a lot into pitching these arts competitions. So, you know, maybe, just maybe, he knew he really couldn't compete on the sports side, but, you know, he wanted his shot at the gold. If there was a podcast Olympics and I'd get a gold medal, I would
你知道的，那是艺术被纳入奥运会的头一年。但显然，我忍不住怀疑他是不是暗中怀有第二种动机。我的意思是，他在推销这些艺术比赛上花了很多心思。所以，你知道的，也许，只是也许，他知道自己在体育方面确实无法竞争，但你知道的，他想抓住机会赢得金牌。如果有一个播客奥运会，而我能拿到金牌，我会
totally into it. Right. You could found it and then submit your work to it and be the best. Love it. Oh, I really do love it. Well, that's so great. I want to bring this back. I would love to see what Michael Phelps could do when it comes to designing a stadium. And right now it would be so awesome. Or how well he can sculpt. I mean, I don't know. Like the possibilities are endless.
完全投入其中。对。你可以创立它，然后把你的作品提交给它，然后成为最棒的。太棒了。哦，我真的很喜欢。嗯，这太棒了。我想把这个带回来。我很想看看迈克尔·菲尔普斯在设计体育场时能做些什么。现在看来这会太棒了。或者他的雕塑水平如何。我的意思是，我不知道。就像可能性是无限的。
Well, I love imagining an Olympics like that. Thanks, Kurt. Coming up, Modernism and Penguins collide after this. Okay, Delaney Hall, what is your mini story for this year? Well, for months there's been this story that's been kicking around in our pitch meetings and it is about the Penguin Pool at the London Zoo. Okay. And when the pool was originally built in 1934, it was this groundbreaking work of engineering.
嗯，我很喜欢想象那样的一场奥运会。谢谢，库尔特。接下来，现代主义与企鹅在接下来的内容中碰撞。好吧，德兰尼·霍尔，你今年的迷你故事是什么？嗯，几个月来，在我们的选题会上一直流传着这样一个故事，它是关于伦敦动物园企鹅池的。好的。当这个水池最初在1934年建造时，这是一项具有突破性的工程。
But there is also a lot of drama over the pool, which is now empty, and big questions about what to do with it. I love the idea of drama about a penguin pool. So, what is so special about this pool? Well, I will get to that, but first, if you will allow me a brief digression into zoo history. I will always allow you all digressions.
但围绕这个现在已经空置的水池，也存在着很多戏剧性的争议，以及关于如何处理它的巨大疑问。我喜欢关于企鹅池的戏剧性故事。那么，这个水池有什么特别之处呢？嗯，我会讲到这一点，但首先，请允许我简短地扯到动物园的历史上。我总是允许你们扯远。
This empire was built on digressions. This empire was built on digressions. Okay, well here is the digressions. So modern zoos, let's start there. Modern zoos date back to the mid 19th century. And one of the first was actually the London Zoo. It was established in 1828. And that was a time when the natural sciences were blossoming. So classification and taxonomy were all the rage. And you can see that reflected in zoo design of the time. So that's kind of where you get the idea of the cat house and the monkey house and the reptile house. So as soon as they started dividing animals taxonomically, then they started to put them in different houses. And that's still like you still see that in zoos today. Like as soon as you walk
这个帝国是建立在题外话之上的。这个帝国是建立在题外话之上的。好吧，这就是题外话。所以现代动物园，让我们从那里开始。现代动物园可以追溯到19世纪中叶。最早的其中之一实际上就是伦敦动物园。它成立于1828年。那是自然科学蓬勃发展的时期。所以分类学和分类法非常流行。你可以从当时的动物园设计中看到这一点。所以这就是猫科动物馆、猴山和爬行动物馆这些概念的来源。因此，一旦他们开始按分类学划分动物，他们就会把它们放在不同的馆里。这仍然——你在今天的动物园里还能看到这一点。就像你一走进去
in to the zoo, like the monkey house is there. Right. But the thing about zoos back then is that even though there was this growing appreciation for the natural world, zoos were basically still, you know, jails for animals. Animals were kept tightly chained in small cages. The lifespan of the typical zoo animal was quite short. I mean, you can imagine that that's not a way any animal should live. Was there a point when that started to get a little bit better? What would they start to do to change that? Yeah. By the mid-20th century, there are a couple big things happening in Zoo Design. One is the decline of cages with bars. So, Zoo Designers are starting to make exhibits that are instead surrounded by moats of water. They're less explicitly cage-like.
走进动物园，猴山就在那里。对。但那个时期动物园的问题在于，尽管人们对自然世界的欣赏日益增加，但动物园基本上仍然是动物的监狱。动物被紧紧地锁在小笼子里。典型动物园动物的寿命相当短。我的意思是，你可以想象这绝不是任何动物应该过的生活。有没有一个时间点，这种情况开始变得好一点了？他们开始做些什么来改变这种状况呢？是的。到了20世纪中叶，动物园设计中发生了几件大事。一是带栏杆的笼子的减少。因此，动物园设计师开始设计取而代之的是由水沟环绕的展区。它们不那么像明目张胆的笼子了。
And then, on the other hand, there's this other trend happening, which is towards modernist zoo design. And, you know, here, we love modernism and all, but I can imagine the clash of modernism and, you know, zoo design, having some problems. Yes, absolutely. I mean, we love modernism. I don't know that animals love modernism. You know, like, not super comfortable for the animals.
然后，另一方面，还有另一个趋势，那就是朝着现代主义动物园设计的方向发展。而且，你知道，在这里，我们很喜欢现代主义，但我可以想象现代主义和动物园设计的冲突，会有一些问题。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，我们喜欢现代主义。我不知道动物是否喜欢现代主义。你知道的，对于动物来说并不是超级舒服。
Fair enough. So these modernist exhibits have concrete cubes and blocky sculptural elements. And there is an argument being made in favor of these new environments. You know, zoo designers say they're clean. They're easily hosed down. They're very sterile. But as we'll see, they're not always the friendliest spaces for animals. And that is where we get back to the famous penguin pool. So here's a picture of the pool for you to check out.
也是。所以这些现代主义展区有混凝土立方体和块状的雕塑元素。人们为这些新环境提出了支持的论点。你知道的，动物园设计师说它们很干净。它们很容易用软管冲洗。它们非常无菌。但正如我们将看到的，它们并不总是对动物最友好的空间。这就是我们回到著名的企鹅池的地方。这里有一张水池的照片供你查看。
Okay. So this is a, there's basically a pool area created. There's a people observing from like, I don't know, the second level. And then there is this sort of double helix of ramps kind of curving around each other. As a set of shapes, it's actually pretty beautiful. Yeah, it is, it is like zoo exhibit as art. but it does not look like a habitat. But it was very popular when it first opened. So here's an old video clip of a reporter visiting the enclosure back in the 30s. So it's left right, left right, round the pool and up the plank. You see the penguins walking up and down the spirals and swimming in the shallow pool below them.
好吧。所以这是一个，基本上创建了一个水池区域。有人在观察，从某种程度上说，比如从第二层。然后是这种双螺旋状的坡道，相互弯曲。作为一个形状组合，它其实非常美丽。是的，它是，它就像是作为艺术品的动物园展区。但它看起来不像一个自然栖息地。但它在刚开放时非常受欢迎。这里有一段老视频剪辑，是一位记者在30年代参观这个围场的情景。所以是左右，左右，绕着水池，走上木板。你可以看到企鹅在螺旋坡道上下行走，在下面浅水池里游泳。
And the concept was fairly clever. Like, penguins could march up and around the ramps. It gave them some room to wander, and it also brought them up to eye level with the spectators. Yeah. So who designed this, this particular pool? The designer was an architect named Bertold Lubikin, but a lot of the credit also goes to Ove Arab. Oh yeah yeah yeah he's that I mean this is like the company Arab, the structural engineering company, is behind
这个概念相当巧妙。企鹅可以沿着坡道向上和周围行进。这给它们提供了一些漫步的空间，同时也把它们带到了与观众平视的高度。是的。那么是谁设计了这个特定的水池呢？设计者是一位名叫伯托尔德·卢比金的建筑师，但很多功劳也归功于奥维·阿鲁普。哦，对，对，他就是那个——我的意思是，这就是奥鲁普公司，这家结构工程公司，在幕后支持着
tons of amazing structures including the Sydney Opera House. Yeah lots of things. Yeah exactly and part of Arab's reputation came from projects like the pool. He was behind the pool's iconic, reinforced concrete ramps. And the engineering firm, Keir, that Arab worked for when he built the ramps, still holds them up many decades later as an example of their groundbreaking work. So here's one of their promotional videos. In this case, it was expertise in concrete that led to
无数令人惊叹的建筑，包括悉尼歌剧院。是的，很多东西。是的，确实如此，阿鲁普的一部分声誉来自于像这个水池这样的项目。他打造了水池标志性的钢筋混凝土坡道。阿鲁普工作过的基尔工程公司，在建造了这些坡道几十年后，仍然将其作为他们突破性工作的典范。所以这是他们的一段宣传视频。在这种情况下，正是混凝土方面的专业知识促成了
care engineer of Arup developing the groundbreaking torsion-reinforced concrete system that allows the interlocking spiral ramps to float in space. So it's pretty look at. The ramps are amazing. It's sort of an engineering feat. The pool is still there, but you'd mentioned that it's empty. Like, that doesn't hold penguins anymore. So why did that happen?
阿鲁普Care工程公司开发了突破性的扭转加固混凝土系统，使得互锁的螺旋坡道能够在太空中悬浮。所以看起来很美观。坡道太惊艳了。这简直是一项工程壮举。水池还在那里，但你提到它已经空了。也就是说，那里不再有企鹅了。那么为什么会这样呢？
Well, this is where the controversy comes in. And where we start to see the limits of building exhibits that are more about design than about creating a livable habitat for animals. So what happened is that, kind of surprisingly, for 50 years or so, penguins lived in the pool area with few problems. We don't know if they liked living there, but they were relatively healthy. Then eventually, zookeepers started noticing a problem, which was that penguins were getting infections, specifically something called bumblefoot. Oh, no.
嗯，这就是争议所在。这也是我们开始看到那些比起为动物创造宜居栖息地，更注重设计的展区的局限性的地方。发生的事情是，有点令人惊讶的是，在50年左右的时间里，企鹅在这个水池区域生活得没有什么问题。我们不知道它们是否喜欢住在那里，但它们的健康状况相对良好。后来，动物园管理员开始注意到一个问题，那就是企鹅开始受到感染，具体来说是一种叫做趾瘤病的病。哦，不。
What's bumblefoot? It sounds both like kind of cutesy and terrifying at the same time. No, it sounds like a disease that would just happen in penguins. It actually afflicts various animals, but... Well, it would happen in the potter versus something like that. Yes. So it is a kind of bacterial infection, and it seems like what happened is that a few decades ago, the pool was renovated.
什么是趾瘤病？听起来既可爱又可怕。不，听起来这只是一种会发生在企鹅身上的疾病。它实际上折磨着各种动物，但是……嗯，它会发生在波特（Potter）身上或其他类似的东西上。是的。所以这是一种细菌感染，看起来发生的情况是，几十年前，水池进行了翻新。
And during that process, the zoo swapped out the original rubber pool side paving for concrete. And they also added these quartz granules to make the surface less slippery. Less slippery for penguins? Why do penguins need to be less slippery? They live on ice. I don't understand that at all. Not all penguins. Not all penguins.
在这个过程中，动物园用混凝土替换了最初的橡胶水池边缘铺装。他们还添加了石英颗粒，使表面不那么滑。对企鹅来说不那么滑？为什么企鹅需要不那么滑？它们生活在冰上。我完全不理解这一点。并不是所有的企鹅。并非所有企鹅都这样。
Oh, okay. I guess they don't, but still. Like, so effectively, they're walking on this really rough surface that's scratching up their feet and then leads to infection. Yes, exactly. So the changes in the material led to wounded feet, which I think led to the infections. But it's also a little more complicated than that
哦，好吧。我想它们不是，但依然如此。所以实际上，它们走在这个非常粗糙的表面上，划破了它们的脚，然后导致了感染。是的，完全正确。因此材质的改变导致了脚部受伤，我认为这导致了感染。但事情也比这稍微复杂一点
because a guy named John Allen, who worked on restoring the pool, he's spoken about this and he says that the original birds selected for the pool were an Antarctic species that generally huddles together. And then when those penguins were swapped out for species that prefers to burrow, the habitat just wasn't as well suited for them. So it seems like it was related to the redesign, but also to the changing of the species, and some combination of how the species interacted with the built environment. Okay, so this guy John Allen, he wasn't convinced that it was just the concrete causing the
因为一个名叫约翰·艾伦的人，他曾参与修复这个水池，他谈到了这一点，他说最初为水池选择的鸟类是一种南极物种，通常会挤在一起。然后当这些企鹅被替换成喜欢挖洞的物种时，这个栖息地对它们来说就不那么合适了。所以这似乎与重新设计有关，但也与物种的更换有关，以及物种与建筑环境相互作用的某种组合。好吧，所以这个叫约翰·艾伦的人，他并不确信仅仅是混凝土造成了
problem. Right, right. So that it was just the concrete causing the problem. Right. Right. So that's part of the tension. There's this question of who's to blame for the pool failing the penguins. The other big debate is what to do with the pool now because it has just been sitting there completely empty. Right.
问题。对，对。所以仅仅是混凝土造成了问题。对。对。所以这也是紧张局势的一部分。这里有一个问题：谁该为水池对企鹅的失败负责。另一个主要的争论是现在如何处理这个水池，因为它一直就那样完全空着。对。
Well, presumably you just replace it with a penguin pool that actually works. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. You would think so. I mean, even the architect's own daughter, Sasha, has suggested they can just quote, blow it to smithereens and move on. She says the pool has outlived his usefulness. But I can already see what's coming down the pike here because this thing is this engineering feat. It's more of an architectural issue than a penguin issue. So I take it. There's some preservation. It's out there that want to keep it. Yeah. Some preservationists really want to save it. It is a historical landmark. One, especially vocal London
嗯，大概你只要把它换成一个真正能用的企鹅池就行了。对。对。完全正确。你会这么想的。我的意思是，连建筑师自己的女儿萨莎都建议他们可以直接引用，“把它炸成碎片然后继续前进”。她说这个水池已经失去了它的实用价值。但我已经能预见到接下来会发生什么了，因为这个东西是一个工程壮举。这更多是一个建筑问题，而不是一个企鹅问题。所以我认为。有一些文物保护主义者。外面有人想要保留它。对。一些文物保护主义者真的想拯救它。这是一个历史地标。一个特别直言不讳的伦敦
newspaper editor wrote that tearing the place down would be a quote, active cultural vandalism. And he called Sasha's statement about blowing up her father's pool quote, patricidal. That's pretty dramatic. Okay, well, I guess that's what newspaper editors and opinion column is gonna have to do for the earn their keep, but it is kind of amazing when you boil it down That this is this is all over a pool for penguins
报纸编辑写道，拆除这个地方将被称为引用，“积极的文化破坏”。他称萨莎关于炸毁她父亲的水池的言论是引用，“弑父”。这太戏剧化了。好吧，我想这就是报纸编辑和专栏作家为了混口饭吃不得不做的事，但当你归结到底时，这确实有点神奇，因为这全部都是为了一个企鹅池
Mm-hmm, and so where do the London Zeus penguins live now? Well the penguins have been moved to a new penguin beach and the beach is indicative of The latest trends in zoo design, which is, you know, they're trying to more faithfully recreate the actual native habitats of the animals who live there. So in the case of the beach, that's a South American beach landscape with lots of plants and water. The water is deep enough for diving. There's sand that the penguins can can grow in, which is an important part of their mating ritual.
嗯哼，那么伦敦动物园的企鹅现在住在哪里呢？嗯，企鹅们已经被转移到了一片新的企鹅滩，而这片海滩象征着动物园设计的最新趋势，你知道的，他们正试图更忠实地重现生活在那里的动物的实际自然栖息地。所以就海滩而言，那是一个南美海滩景观，有许多植物和水。水深足够潜水。有沙子供企鹅在其中生长，这是它们求偶仪式的重要部分。
And then there's rocks for the penguins, you know, little feet to walk on, instead of concrete with quartz granules. So it mimics the places these penguins actually live in the wild. Here's one of the zookeepers. The previous pool that we used to keep the penguins in beforehand was, okay, but it didn't have all the new, wizzy kind of exhibit penguin-friendly adaptations we've got into this pond. Say for instance, the old pool,
然后还有供企鹅（你知道的，小脚）行走的岩石，而不是带有石英颗粒的混凝土。所以它模仿了这些企鹅在野外实际居住的地方。这里有一位动物园管理员。我们以前用来养企鹅的那个旧水池还可以，但它没有我们现在在这个池塘里拥有的所有那些新潮的、对企鹅友好的改造。比方说，旧水池，
you used to see the penguins swimming around. I mean, it sounds like they actually kind of settled on an interesting compromise, which is they have a penguin habitat that actually functions have a penguin habitat that is actually functions as a penguin habitat. And if they want to keep those ramps around, just to look at them, you know, more power to them. I don't think it's their place.
你以前经常看到企鹅在里面游来游去。我的意思是，听起来他们实际上达成了一个有趣的妥协，那就是他们拥有了一个真正能运作的企鹅栖息地，一个真正作为企鹅栖息地运作的栖息地。如果他们想把这些坡道留着，只是为了看着它们，你知道的，那是他们的自由。我不认为这是他们的地方。
They can decide what to do with it or not, I suppose. It's true. You can put little stuffed penguins all around it and show how it used to work or something. Little animatronic penguins. Yeah, or it's's just a diorama. Yeah, they could go full, like, New York Natural History Museum with those weird, totally. I remember.
他们可以决定如何处理它或者不处理，我想是的。确实如此。你可以把小毛绒企鹅放在它周围，展示它过去是如何工作的之类的。小型电子动画企鹅。是的，或者它只是一个立体模型。是的，他们可以去全面打造，就像纽约自然历史博物馆里那些奇怪的布景一样，完全是这样。我记得。
Yeah, but it has less to do with natural history and more to do with engineering history. And then there's a little architectural lesson as soon as you enter the zoo. Which is not what most kids will expect or enjoy. But we will. Yeah, we'll like it. Just concrete, no animals. Well, thank you, Tulaney. That's a we will. We'll like it. Just come through.
是的，但这与自然历史的关系较小，而与工程历史的关系更大。一进入动物园，就会有一个小小的建筑学课程。这并不是大多数孩子所期望或喜欢的。但我们会。是的，我们会喜欢的。只有混凝土，没有动物。好吧，谢谢你，德兰尼。这是一个我们会喜欢的。我们会喜欢的。只有混凝土。
No animals. Well, thank you, Delaney. That's just a fascinating place. I had no idea. Yeah, of course. Thanks so much, Roman. As always, there's lots of images and videos of the pool at our website, it's 99pi.org.
没有动物。好吧，谢谢你，德兰尼。那真是一个迷人的地方。我完全不知道。是的，当然。非常感谢，罗曼。像往常一样，我们的网站上有许多关于这个水池的图片和视频，网址是 99pi.org。
99% of visible was produced this week by Chris Perube, Kurt Colstad and Delaney Hall, Mixing Tech Production by Amida Ganatra, Music by our director of Sound, Swan Riau, The Resident Team, Is Vivian Le, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemba Dawn, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to my old officemate Mary Rochew, I wish I still got lunch with every day. You should read all of her books, she's the best. We are a part of this Ditcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, being beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join
本周的 99%无形是由克里斯·佩鲁韦、库尔特·科尔斯特德和德兰尼·霍尔制作的，混音技术制作由阿米达·加纳特拉完成，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里奥创作，常驻团队有维万·勒、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、拉谢姆巴·唐、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢我的老办公室同事玛丽·罗谢夫，我希望我每天还能和她一起吃午饭。你应该读她所有的书，她是最好的。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼，风景优美。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并加入
discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org. Want Instagram and write it too. You can find links to other stitch or shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. That is a wrap for us for 2021. We'll be back with a new episode of Minis in 2022. Remember it'll all be okay in the end. And if it's not okay, it's not the end. Stitcher, it's your sex home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以在节目@ 99PI org。也想要 Instagram 并且写下来。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一个往期节目。我们在 2021 年的节目就到此结束了。我们将在 2022 年带着全新的迷你节目回归。记住，结局一切都会好的。如果现在不好，那就不是结局。Stitcher，这是你的性之家。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来发表评论。